wir sind auf der suche nach
außerirdischem leben einen riesenschritt
weiter gekommen
die nasa hat mehr als 700 neue
extrasolare planeten entdeckt werden wir
den aliens finden jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction
es ist ein neuer rekord und ein
meilenstein auf der suche nach
außerirdischer intelligenz 715 neue
exoplaneten so viele wurden noch nie in
einem jahr entdeckt 2014 ist damit das
jahr der exoplaneten die zentrale frage
aber ist gibt es dort leben die
planetenforschung ist noch eine relativ
junge disziplin denn erst anfang der
90er jahre wurden die ersten planeten
außerhalb unseres sonnensystems entdeckt
bis dahin gab es schlichtweg keine
methode planeten zu finden und es wäre
theoretisch sogar möglich gewesen
das ist gar keine planeten außerhalb
unseres sonnensystems gegeben hätte mit
der entdeckung von drei planeten geben
impulse psr 12 57 5 12 kreisen durch den
polnischen astronomen alexander wolf
schaden wurde das 1992 anders der pulsar
puls die nämlich unregelmäßig da
planeten seine strahl blockierten
durch genaue bestimmung dieser
unregelmäßigkeiten konnten drei planeten
mit 0 02 43 und 3,9 erdmassen entdeckt
werden es waren damit die ersten
planeten die zweifelsfrei existiert 1995
wurde dann der erste planet der um einen
stern ähnlich unserer sonne kreist
entdeckt planet 51 pegasi b kreist um
einen stern im sternbild pegasus
seine entdecker hatten festgestellt dass
der stern 51 pegasi im alle herum eiert
verursacht durch einen planeten der
umkreist man hat der stärke dieses 1
konnten sie sogar die größe des planeten
errechnen 0,46 jupitermassen so langsam
kann überleben suche in fahrt jetzt ging
es darum planeten aufzuspüren die erd-
ähnlich sind und damit leben ermöglichen
es war wie die nadel im heuhaufen zu
suchen die meisten plan
war es zu heiß zu kalt zu klein zu groß
es gab kein wasser auf ihn oder sie
greifen zu nah um ihr zentralgestirn
doch in den letzten jahren wurden immer
mehr planeten entdeckt und damit auch
immer mehr auf denen leben möglich ist
eine bedingung ist die entfernung der
planeten zum stern um den sieg reisen
sie müssen sich in der sogenannten
goldlöckchen zone die heißt wirklich so
der habitablen zone befinden benannt ist
diese zone nach dem märchen über das
goldlöckchen das zuerst zu heißen brei
ist dann zu kalten und dann breit er
richtig temperiert ist denn das ist die
wichtigste bedingung es darf auf dem
planeten nicht zu heiß und nicht zu kalt
sein damit leben entstehen kann und es
gibt planeten auf denen diese
bedingungen gelten und auf dem sogar
ausreichend wasser vorhanden ist
allerdings sind das nur sehr wenige ließ
12 14 w ist einer von ihnen und
vielleicht derjenige mit dem besten
bekannten lebensbedingungen er hat den
richtigen abstand zum zentralgestirn
einem roten zwerg also einen kleinen
nicht sehr heißen stern und ließ 12 14 b
verfügt über eine atmosphäre mit einer
menge wasserdampf hier sind die chancen
am größten das leben dort existiert
allerdings ist glies 12 14 b rund 40
lichtjahre von uns entfernt für uns zur
zeit unerreichbar doch es werden immer
mehr erdähnliche planeten entdeckt bei
den jetzt gemeldeten 700 extrasolaren
planeten sind immerhin vier super erden
dabei das heißt gesteinsplaneten mit
mehreren erdmassen mit erdähnlichen
bedingungen die chancen jetzt wirklich
leben auf diesen super erden zu finden
stehen gar nicht mal so schlecht die
rechnung der wissenschaftler ist dabei
ziemlich simpel
erstens sie gehen davon aus das leben
unter optimalen bedingungen entstehen
muss und zweitens um so mehr erdähnliche
planeten es gibt desto größer sind die
chancen dass auch ein planet darunter
ist mit optimalen bedingungen dort also
leben entstanden sein muss
wir können also gespannt sein welche
planeten noch in zukunft entdeckt werden
und wann wir das erste mal einen beweis
für außerirdisches leben finden was
meint ihr werden wir aliens finden oder
sind wir ganz alleine
wird es in diesem jahrhundert den ersten
kontakt geben oder ist das unmöglich
diskutiert dass in den kommentaren mehr
zu klicks um science-fiction gibt es
aliens zehn gründe für ihre existenz
oder das letzte video so funktioniert
youtube und so nutzt du es so wie du es
willst galileo war gestern hier kommt
ein update 2.0 klicks um science-fiction
abonnieren oder parieren
und da oben gehts zum blog ja und dann
geht's nach links und rechts